so what i'm saying it i have i put faith
in those two things together that's what
i'm saying
yosh i was going to ask if you have any
comments on that
yeah we found that we uh join and meet
don't have uh differences at least not
in the
discussion that we had in the last
couple hours we mostly had very similar
approaches and ideas and we developed
our terms together in ways that was very
harmonic
we might have a difference in the reason
why we do things it seems to me that
john has a different relationship to
normativity than me and maybe we can go
into this question later but basically
from my perspective looks like john sees
himself as a spiritual teacher
and i don't have enough
maturity to see myself as a spiritual
teacher with integrity i also don't know
what i would get out of this
my
own observation of the meaning crisis is
that it's inevitable because the
civilization that we are part of doesn't
have much of a future
and
there is no way in which the
civilization can be fixed without
changing some of its core assumptions
and
so uh we sense this and we it's
reflected in the fact that our
civilization is not projecting itself
into the future we have no models that
we discuss with our children in school
or in our institutions we have no plans
that go beyond the next few decades it's
not that we actually think about what
will life on earth look like for our
civilization in 500 years from now
and that's new that this was not true in
the christian society for instance they
had an idea of what was going to happen
in a few hundred years from then and
this idea might have been wrong but they
made plans for it and some of these
plans came to pass and we don't have
that kind of planning horizon anymore so
we basically are now in an organism as a
hyper organism
uh that is past its prime that is in
some sense visibly in its autumn and
that is
facing off against all sorts of
existential risks and we feel helpless
at dealing with these risks and as a
result we don't have a shared purpose we
might have a shared purpose as an
individual with a family with children
with friends but we don't seem to
project this shared purpose anymore at a
societal level and there are only small
groups within the societies some
evangelical cults and transhumanist
skulls and so on that try to maintain
the fiction of a future that they're
acting with but not at the level of the
entire civilization it is the level of
this individual group
and our mainstream uh geist deals with
this mostly by uh despair or denial yes
and uh or even an outright
nihilism and i don't have an argument
against that nihilism because i think
that from the perspective of the
uh civilizational hive mind this is
justified
and if we want to build something new we
have to do this from the vantage point
of the next civilization and that's
almost impossible to maintain the space
in your own mind what the next
civilization would be looking like and
how to build it
so the only thing that i have to offer
in terms of spiritual guidance is that i
hug my friends and uh there's not that
much more and uh and so it's more
when we need the possibility that i
could offer somebody that i say this is
how you fix your life this is how you
fix your relationship to the world this
is how you fix your relationship to
society and this is how you fix your
society itself because they don't have
these kinds of answers i don't know what
these answers would look like i'm
willing to look for them i'm willing to
look for them with others but i'm not uh
convinced that there is an answer
and instead there is more place that we
can get to in this place comes from
attempt to develop integrity and to be
truthful and i agree with john that
truth is crucial because truth is
instrumental to good regulation it's
even reflected in cybernetics in the
good regulator theorem you cannot
uh regulate reality when you're not
truthful about it so the attempt to bend
your worldview to make it more desirable
to deny the things that don't fit into
the world that you prefer as the just
one and so on is not going to lead to a
better world it's going to lead to a
world that is worse
and so you need when you want to model
the world do this in a space that is
independent of what you want to be true
so there need to be two parts of us one
that is modeling the world this
detachment
but uh it's not important who is looking
at the world and why and another one
where you make your personal bets and
where you construct your aesthetics
based on what you think is true
and
this separation is something that is not
a consensus in the
disciplines that think about what the
world should be looking like so for
instance there are very few sociologists
that look at the world with detachment
they largely do this from a very local
perspective that is congruent with what
their friends think and that is
basically characterized by the present
ideology and i don't think that you can
be ideological and truthful at the same
time where the allergy
commits you to seeing the certain way
of the things that are happening in the
world regardless of the facts
that you are observing and it makes you
inclined to pick certain facts over
others to support this particular kind
of aesthetic and for me the aesthetic is
something that needs to be developed
independently of the reasoning about
what is the case
and since the most people that think
normatively prefer to be part of the
hivemind before they are truthful
autonomously i have difficulty with the
general notion of normativity my own
thinking is when i do philosophy
primarily not normative
i'm thinking about everything that could
be the case i'm not thinking about what
should be the case every should is an if
then
um
there's a lot i i have in agreement with
about uh what you said there uh about
the the meaning crisis
um i guess part of
what
i i don't know if
i'm like a spiritual teacher or not but
uh
but nevertheless um perhaps what i would
say is i think you were proposing a lot
of what goes into the notion of wisdom
a concern for the truth the ability to
detach from an egocentric perspective uh
pursuing integrity um
etc
um
and i think it's
one of the things we should do is
consider
uh increasing the wisdom of people um i
think that's a viable project
um and in conjunction with that
um
i
i think we should do what
uh what has typically happened when
civilizations have collapsed uh the
bronze age collapse or perhaps the
collapse of the western roman empire
right you had
you had
the building of new communities
and communities of communities that made
possible new ways of life for people
and were able to
take
salvage
what the the
previous civil legislation had done and
exact it into the next civilization a
prototypical example of this is be
somebody like augustine you know the
barbarians are literally at the gate and
he is shepherding
sort of the greco-roman heritage into
christianity and he's modifying it he's
coming up with a new way of being he's
the autobiographical self comes into
kind of awareness
you know there's a new way of being a
person new way of being a community new
way of being in relationship to the
world i'm not saying he did this
single-handedly i'm just using it as a
case and he helps to build
the possibilities of the next
civilization
now i'm not arrogant i hope i'm not so
arrogant to think and i know i'm
augustine and i know what it is it's
going to be turn up i think we should be
getting a lot of people trying to build
right these models these ways
because
typically if you have that kind of a
translation
process already in place
you get to the next civilization with
much less suffering
i'm not convinced that
we can like you that we can save this
what we have
but i guess i want to find out what is
the best way individually and
collectively
of collecting the candles from what we
have made so that we can carry them into
and make it possible for our children
um
and so this is for me a way of trying to
get back
to
the a generational relationship like you
were talking about where it's not just
me here now in distraction or despair
but trying to ask
like and i don't mean this
technologically or sociologically or
politically
trying to ask
look for
where are people trying to build what
looked like viable possible new ways
for being in a civilization
and we know that this has been done in
the past
and
this isn't an algorithm it can't be but
we can look at those historical figures
we can look at many of those historical
examples and try and glean sort of the
best lessons possible that's what i'm
proposing i i i'm definitely not
founding a religion or anything like
that i i i
i'm not the right person for the job i
don't want the job and um so if that's
if that means i see myself as a
spiritual practitioner um so be it i'm
fine with that but i just wanted to
clarify
what i'm proposing i'm i'm proposing
something that is possible at least we
have
i think relevantly similar cases from
history of where this has worked and you
can see it like i say and two i've
looked at carefully at the axial
revolution and also
um
uh the end of the western roman empire
that's what i'm proposing that's what
i'm proposing